- So Elisabeth Moss, as you saw,
we know she beat you.
Like every time, right?
- I don't know about every time.
I think what she said
was she beat me once.
And then I refused to play again.
But yeah, it was the championship.
She won the championship
and then the championship was over.
And then, you know, there was
never another championship.
What a shame.
- That is so sad.
No. What was the game of choice again?
- Well, she played Speed.
But we played a lot of games.
At the Madman base camp
there was dominoes,
there was a lot of cards.
There was Heads Up! There was-
- Did you play X-Men dominoes?
I love that.
- We didn't play that there,
but we played regular old dominoes.
There were a lot of games because
we spent a lot of time there.
- Yeah.
- I was always there
because I'm in every scene.
- Yeah.
- So I would sort of
run the game quotient.
And then if there was one
that I wasn't particularly good at
we shuffled that one
into the back of the...
Into the back of the line.
- We see who you are.
- Yes.
- So wait, you also love poker, right?
Do you do poker nights?
- I play poker.
- Okay.
- I've been in a
actually a game
of poker that's been
running every week since
before I started Mad
Men, which would've been-
- What?
Back in the early 2000s.
But I love playing poker. It's fun.
It's more fun to just
get your friends together
and sit around a table and talk.
- 100%. And it's just kind of the vessel
for that whole gambling scenario.
- Absolutely.
- Okay. I love it.